California is struggling to contain one
of its deadliest wildfire outbreaks the
fires have killed at least 11 people
about 1,500 structures are destroyed
both numbers are expected to grow these
fires move so fast yesterday they put
many more lives in jeopardy this photo
shows one of several neighborhoods in
Santa Rosa that was burned to the ground
in all 15 dangerous wildfires are
burning across the state right now
officials say it is very rare to have so
many fires start at the same time media
viene al is in Santa Rosa part of the
wine country north of San Francisco that
is especially hard-hit you know a good
morning well good morning we're on the
north side of Santa Rosa in the white
oak neighborhood over my shoulder you
can already see flames coming over this
hillside this is a new fire in this area
we can actually hear the crackling of
the fire coming through the brush area
firefighters are nearby standing at the
ready this neighborhood has been
evacuated and the entire city is under
curfew authorities were worried about
looting and unfortunately right now
these scenes of devastation are the same
around the entire region more than a
dozen wildfires raged on in Northern
California overnight
despite desperate attempts by more than
a thousand firefighters to gain the
upper hand the fires fueled by strong
winds broke out almost simultaneously
Sunday forcing crews to spread their
resources across the region
you watched four houses burn Brandon
Hayes says he ignored evacuation orders
to try and save his parents house only
to see it destroyed I pretended to go
and then I turned around and came back
because it's my folks home and I'm not
gonna sit here and watch it burn without
somebody trying tens of thousands of
people were forced to leave as flames
raced into their backyards the fires
destroyed more than a thousand
structures gutting hotels and homes and
turning parts of wine country into a
charred wasteland in some cases flames
were so intense authorities had to
choose saving people over saving homes
it's devastating it's devastating
word Cook tried to douse embers near his
home after realizing fire crews were
stretched thin frustrating but I get the
fact that they've got jobs to do and
they're trying to do them as best they
can with the fires out of control
authorities say it's too early to
determine the full scope of the
devastation or the death toll
there is no searching there is no
looking yet so there is a lot of burned
homes and a lot of burned areas so we
it's just logical that we're gonna find
more people Sonoma County received a
hundred missing-persons reports right
now there are widespread cellphone
outages in the area making communication
very difficult vice president my pens
was in the state of California he says
the federal government stands ready to
help with whatever aid the state needs
Nora all right mother Hannah thank you
so much